hey guys is dense the founder thing here
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the second episode ever
of almost human skin gotta have sex bots
gotta have sex bots so wait what do you
think of the episode I loved it I this
episode i thought was burned the pilot
mhm i like that it didn't take itself
too seriously i thought some parts in
the pilot we're trying to put Karl Urban
his dark we had a dark past and got the
in syndicate not the syndicate but the
innocent to kit and all this stuff going
on in like I don't think care model I
mean it was good but I don't care about
that this one these guys just gotta have
it fun there was a lot of comedy in this
in this episode I liked it better i'm
always a fan of sex bots so you know hey
i'm a fan of sex box but this this was
fun i liked this episode it was fun i am
a more lukewarm oh i didn't like it as
much as you did it did what I was afraid
when I talked to him about in our in the
premier episodes I what I was worried
that they would go into this episodic
thing and it become this CSI case of the
week right and that's kind of what it's
doing now but granted fringe did that as
well and eventually turned into a
fantastic series so I you know the
potential is still there I still like
the characters I still like the dynamic
doing John and Dory and yeah I like the
world no I just didn't particularly care
much for this episode I wasn't really
that interested in the kidnapping of the
the ladies and the sex bots and all that
stuff butter too but i will say i liked
the last five or ten minutes of this
episode yeah I like I think those I
think the moments between Dorian and
John you know I think those were really
touching like in the beginning he's
asking like you know what do you say to
a person when somebody dies and they tie
that into the end that's what i really
like yeah those way twin Doreen who is
you know still a robot an AI goes and
sees that one sex box basically dying
right and those who in saying the
comforting words so I really like that
scene I also really liked the scene of
John at the end going to his part yeah
his dead partners house to see the kid
you know so I really like
at last five or ten minutes I just
wasn't that you know fawn the in between
so I think this is the comedy like it
was like there was like the guy from
parts that Caribbean who plays the the
scientist who you know he was like oh I
gotta insert oops I don't want to say
you know my awkward sexual dialogue it
was good I liked the one character that
worries me though and I'm not I wasn't a
big fan of her in Friday Night Lights
minka kelly words make some time she's a
beautiful woman she's gorgeous simplygh
or i'd just i hope they use her because
i lost you know you and I both love Val
Charlotte suka Spartacus a love strong
female characters I hope she's not just
a pretty face I know it's early another
guy think every time if I hope they give
her a character more to do can make it
go and hopefully there's there some sort
of tension between her and John right
maybe even some feistiness yeah but my
little love finger on it smile um but
yeah ah it's too early to tell from for
about that character is too early to
tell about the show I still think it has
potential i still think it it can be
better i'm just worried that they're
gonna fall into this trap right of every
episode we got a brand new case right i
mean but i did like I think these guys
can hold it up I think it'll be an
advantage even this let's say the season
is episodic I think because it's I'm
assuming it short I don't yeah it's
gonna be 22 episodes so hopefully I hope
they keep this like with sleepy hollow
this is on the same network of Sleepy
Hollow CP Holly decide to renew 13
episodes I hope they do the same thing
with this and keep it just that kind of
small 13-episode not try to cause it was
Karl Urban's movie career I shouldn't
have time to do that also the visual
effects on this show the production
values raised you know yeah yeah yeah
there's funny moments a moment with it
with the the kids that was either Obama
shaking his head yeah like once you some
cool this status yeah some moments like
that I really like I just didn't care
much for the story right this particular
episode I just didn't care about you
know finding the I don't want to sound
like harsh or anything cuz this is just
a TV show this isn't really women's skin
was being harvested to form sex box I
just yeah I just kind of like tune tuned
out for that that that part what I love
about this episode and one thing I love
about sci-fi so if eyes always a great
medium you know whether it's Battlestar
with politics and terrorism just talk
about you know other topics from a safe
distance because it's just a little bit
outside of our realm of understanding
that like the part when it was very
subtle the guy one of the detectives
look I think it's a jerk walked in he's
like yeah you know I used xbox like
whatever is like no big deal in the one
I think the chief or the woman the head
in charge said hey you know it's like
sexual crime has gone down like thirty
percent since they that's just like kind
of interesting topics to talk about like
I liked how sci-fi can do that but I
agree this episode was episodic but I
still enjoyed it okay that's alright
guys so that's what we thought of the
episode did you really like it like
David or where you kind of lukewarm like
me or maybe you hated it or maybes don't
see any potential in this show you can
post your comments below on our website
thank yo calm and on our youtube channel
think Harold pro make sure you subscribe
to that we're gonna share this on on
Twitter I've talked to Dennis myself and
it was here at think hero that's about
what your favorite shows are what are
you liking are you a fan of sex box oh
yeah I find this at think hero i'm at
griffin de and we asked on the facebook
page that's a facebook.com slash think
hero fans and also make sure you like
our page and tweet out our videos and
share them and that'll help out a lot
you